This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. If our 20s could be summarized in any way, I think we could best describe them as the decade of transition so much about who we are, what we like, our environment,
our identity, our relationships as well. in this state of flux. And a lot of that is caused by the very concrete milestones we face. And a huge one for those of us who went on to go to college or university is graduation. For me, when I was at university, it still very much felt like an extension of my high school and teenage years. And adulthood was kind of creeping up into the picture on the sidelines. And even though I had a job, even though I was in what felt like a very adult relationship and I had bills. Uni was this weird vacuum where I still felt like I had a lot of permission to figure things out and be slightly chaotic.
But the further you get into it, the more, like I said, adult life creeps in. And then suddenly you've just blinked and you were walking across the stage and you were getting your diploma. And it kind of feels like at that moment you should have all the answers or at least a few more than you had when you first started. but for so many of us that is the exact opposite. We have no idea what we want to do. We feel increasingly lonely. And sometimes we even get caught up in the nostalgia of those years and what they offered. And I really want to talk about it today.
So I'm bringing on a wonderful guest to discuss the psychology of the post-graduation blues. Welcome, Liz. Tell the audience about yourself a little bit. Thank you so much for having me. It's so nice to talk with you today. Yes, I am a therapist in the Washington, D.C. area, and I'm the author of the book. This book is cheaper than therapy, a known essence guide to improving your mental health. And I work with a lot of young people in their 20s who are just getting out of college and entering the world. And, you know, they're coming to this exciting place, Washington, D.C., but it's not always that easy. Oh, my gosh, I can absolutely imagine, like Washington, D.C., especially, I feel like a lot of the people who would be going, that would be so. ambitious as well? Absolutely. Yeah. So I work with so many incredible people who are smart and
ambitious, but these same qualities can also be challenging when you come to a place like DC where there's so many different options of things to do and it's hard to kind of figure out what your niches and where you want to go. And so I feel really privileged to be able to work with with so many amazing clients to be able to talk about some of these issues. And you know, what I find really, really valuable about that is like, I'm sure there are like some smart cookies in Washington who are like ready to take on politics in the world. And the fact that what we're talking about today still comes up is just a real testament to how universal this is. And what we're talking about is the post-graduation blues. Can you kind of speak to what that actually is? I feel
like it's in the name, but maybe you can give like a bit more color to it. Right. And Absolutely. So in my training as a therapist, I have a lot of experience in working with the grief and loss and bereavement. So I often look at the post-graduation blues through the lens of loss. The loss, so grief is a natural reaction to anything that you cherish or anything that you love. And for a lot of us going to college and going to university, I mean, it's a really amazing experience where with peers, we get to talk about big ideas, we get to learn about really interesting things. and have all these new experiences and live in this area where there's a lot of options for exploring hobbies and social interaction and all of these things. So, you know, it's for many of us, not to say that there aren't challenges, but for many of us, it's such a good experience. And then all of a sudden, after graduation, we're leaving that behind. And that's a real loss.
And any time you have changed plus loss, chances are you're going to experience some feelings of grief. Oh my gosh, absolutely. And it's this sense of like emptiness, right? Like you cherished, as you said, something so highly and it may not have been a person or even anything material, but just like a state of being, like a time in your life that felt so free and so exciting. And I think like a big reason why we experience like post-graduation blues is just like it's just this sense of like, time is moving on and I have to change with that. So what are some of like the big feelings to define this transition? Absolutely. So grief can involve things like so grief sometimes people
think that grief is an emotion but grief isn't actually an emotion. Grief is a whole range of feelings. So it could involve sadness, disappointment, regret, frustration, irritability, numbness. So grief can really be a role. coaster and this roller coaster is pretty common in the post-graduation blues. You know, one day you might feel like you have it all together and you're excited about your future and you're excited about the possibilities. You know, the next day you might be feeling a lot of anxiety because you're unsure of when you're going to get a job or how you're going to pay off debt from university or who you're going to live with. So it can really feel unsettling because it is as writing this
roller coaster of emotions. And I love that. for because that is exactly how I felt when I first graduated uni. And it's like, it was a while ago, but I just remember one day I would wake up and be like, oh my gosh, like I am so young. I'm so excited for my future. I could do anything. And then the next day I'd be like, I'm absolutely paralyzed by the fact that I do not have this figured out. And everyone around me does. Do you think that like that comparison kind of plays a role? Yeah. Absolutely. Absolutely. Because every time we talk to someone else, you know, we're not getting the whole picture. If you see someone post something on LinkedIn or social media or Instagram or wherever,
you know, you're only seeing a very small snapshot to that person's life. And what you're seeing might look incredible and amazing. But chances are there's so many other factors. And I talk to a lot of clients and some of these clients from the outside seem like they have the perfect job and the perfect life, but that doesn't mean that everything feels perfect for them. No, I speak about this so much. And it seems so obvious, right? If I sat down with somebody, a friend of mine and said, hey, did you know that like what you see on social media isn't real? They'd be like, yeah, of course, Gemma, of course I know that. But really actually think about it
in like the deep parts of yourself, like really hold that information because it's very easy to be like, yeah, that's not real. But do you actually believe it? Do you actually believe it to the point where you are no longer comparing yourself to it? And, you know, again, back to my experience, like, LinkedIn was like my, was enemy number one to me when I was job hunting and I was trying to sort things out. Because it, the other component of social media and LinkedIn and those sites is that it is about self-promotion, right? Right. The whole premise is to look your best because people want to look their best for their friends and for, people they know, but also for like future connections and like, you know, future bosses.
So there is like this whole aspect of it that is performative and we just don't see it. Right. Absolutely. We see like the perfectly touched up headshot and the, you know, recent job title and all of these things. And we're not, we're not seeing the struggles that it took to get there or the whole picture behind the seeds. Yeah. And bringing it back to like post-graduation, I feel like it's this huge, sometimes like separation between a lot of people having some part of their future have sorted out or at least seeming like they do. And then this like other side of people just absolutely having no idea. And it does feel like, you know, like the further you get out of school, the more pressure it is to like conform. and the more pressure it is to like have an answer.
What about like that ambiguity is so distressing? That's such a good, a good point because I'm thinking about my clients for some of them who even find their quote unquote perfect job. And then they're in their perfect job and it doesn't feel the way they thought it would feel or that it was more challenging than they thought it would feel. And I think we have all this. pressure more than ever to kind of find our niche, right? You know, we, so many of us were,
it was drummed into us, you know, find your passion, find your passion. And that's an incredibly difficult thing to do in this world where there's so many options, there's so many choices. So what I encourage my clients, rather than to find your passion to, to follow your curiosity because the more curious you are about things and the more you learn about something, the more passionate you're going to become. But, you know, find, your passion is such, you know, that's such a heavy burden to bear because that's just not a easy thing to do. Oh no. It literally is not. And it's also sometimes accidental, right? Like, it is one of those things that when you go looking for it, you never find it. It's like love.
Do you know what I mean? Right. And so it's like you kind of have to do a lot of trial and error. but when it's like you're so used to the structured environment of schooling where it's like, yes, there is like a timeline for everything. There is this ultimate goal that you're always working towards. That like it is a privilege to be able to explore the privilege to have choices. Feels very daunting. You know, I'm sure like a lot of your clients come to you and are like, oh, maybe I should go back and do my master's or something like that.
do you think that sometimes we find a lot of comfort in like that structure and that's why we want to return to school or like that's why we find ourselves like drawn back to those environments? Right. Absolutely. I think when we get uncertain or unsteady, we crave stability and we crave security and safety and for some they think, well, I'll get my master's or I'll go back to school because then I can have that safety and security again, at least for a little while. Yeah. And then it just puts you in like so much more debt. Right. Exactly. But, but really, it's just sort of postponing, postponing that insecurity or that, that instability. And I think
for some of us or a lot of work with my clients, involves getting comfortable with being uncomfortable and getting, getting more comfortable being, you know, sitting with discomfort, right? You know, sitting with the fact that like, it's okay that I don't have it all figured out. It's okay that I don't know where I'm going to be in five years or 10 years or it's okay that I don't know exactly what I want my career to look like. And if we can kind of get to that place, it becomes easier to tolerate. And I really like that point of like, I think once the discomfort becomes easier to tolerate, it's less of a factor in your decision making. Have you found that? Like once people are comfortable, they actually find it easier to be like, yeah, I can commit to something or I can
be more open to opportunity. Exactly. I think it takes sitting, being able to sit with discomfort makes it easier to take that first step. Because I think when we're when we're so afraid of being uncomfortable, we're sort of looking for the perfect thing or it's really easy to kind of shut down, right? But what we want to do is be able to take baby steps, right? And be able to say to ourselves, like, I don't have it all figured out, but this job seems interesting or I like doing these types of tasks or I'm curious about this field and being able to just take those tiny steps that are going to gradually, you know, lead us in the direction of where we want to go personally, professionally.
Yeah. And it's like chasing curiosity instead of chasing like perfection and chasing like security. Right. It's like I don't actually need to have it all figured out. That's not my criteria for saying yes. Like my criteria for saying yes is not that this needs to be part of like a huge lifelong plan. It's like, is this like something that I'm excited by right now? out. Right. Exactly. So, okay, the loss of like that academic structured environment is a huge component, but another huge part, which I honestly think is like a bigger element of this. And I feel like you know what I'm going to say, but it's like relationships, right? It's friendships. Right. And, you know, I went to like a university that a lot of people came from out of state
to come to, which is not very common in Australia, but I'm sure I think in the US and other places it is more common. And there was like this period like of like six months after I graduated of like a mass exodus where everyone just like dispersed. And I think that really like contributed to a lot of the stress. Why do you think it is that, you know, those loss of relationships can be so uncomfortable, even if we know it's going to happen. Well, college or university, you know, your whole life up until that point, you've always been together with a group of peers. You've always had a group of people in similar circumstances and similar age. And now all of a sudden, like, you lose that. And that's, again, kind of coming back to the loss.
That's a really big loss of just not having a large group of people who are all going through similar circumstances. You know, then all of a sudden you're in your first job and you're working with people of all different ages or you're back at home and you're with your family. And it's, and it just doesn't feel the same. And even if you're still staying in touch with your friends, you know, you don't get to see them for lunch every day or you don't get to study with them every afternoon. And so these changes in your routine can really be hard to adjust to. Oh, I totally found that in my circumstances. It was like the shift from having, they were part of my routine, right? They're part of our errands. They're part of our daily lives. I would see them like every single.
day sometimes multiple times a day because we lived so close everybody was doing the same thing and now it's like the shift to a lot of long distance friendships that's a huge one right but then also it's like this fragmentation where it's like okay some of us are traveling and some of some of my friends are like move back home with their parents and some of them are getting married and some of them are doing their masters or unemployed and there is no longer this like I think shared touchpoint, the shared thing that we're all going through, which is uni, which is college, which is like school. So it's like, you know, I'm sure you obviously know this, but it's like one of the biggest things is like similarity of experiences. Do you see a lot of your clients not just like,
you know, it's not just that they feel like they're no longer in touch with their friends, but they're losing them all together? Absolutely. I also see. My clients go through, maybe the way to put it is like friendship drift where relationships are kind of grow apart. And they still treasure that time that they had in school together, but they just aren't as close. And the relationship maybe doesn't feel the same or if they have a reunion a year later, it just doesn't feel the way they expected it to feel. And some friendships even end or people grow apart. And that doesn't mean that anybody's done anything wrong or that you made a mistake.
It just this, this happens sometimes. And I try to encourage my clients to think about the fact that even if a friendship drifts apart or even if it ends, it doesn't mean that the time you had together in university wasn't meaningful. That's relationships.
So it could have been incredibly meaningful for that time and for your development and for what you learned about like yourself in the world. But sometimes friendships do change over time. What advice would you have for people going through that? Because I feel like it's normally not just one, right? It's normally like a group of people or it's a whole like system that, not system, but like a whole friendship structure that kind of falls apart. So what advice would you have for somebody experiencing that? So my first advice would be to name and accept what you're feeling.
So if you're feeling loss or sadness or disappointment or frustration to be able to name it. be able to accept it without judgments and be able to say, like, I'm feeling really sad right now. And that's okay. Because sometimes what happens is we'll feel sad or we'll feel disappointed, but then we'll shame ourselves for having that feeling, right? Like we'll say, you know, I'm feeling sad, but I shouldn't feel sad because I've got so much going for me or other people have it worse. And then now we feel guilty and sad, which doesn't help anybody, right?
So, you know, being able to acknowledge and accept your feelings and without judging them, that can help the feeling kind of move through you a little bit more quickly. And by kind of accepting those emotions and and also learning to hold two emotions at the same time can be really important. You know, I'm feeling sad and I'm also feeling excited about the possibilities. You know, both of those things can be true at the same time. And once we can kind of start to interact with our feelings differently, that frees us up to be able to take small actions of like, you know, maybe tomorrow I'm going to study at a new coffee shop or I'm going to job hunt at a new coffee shop or I'm going to, you know, ask that person to meet up for a walk. So we can start to reestablish and create new
relationships. Yeah. And it's like not just holding to emotions, but holding to truths. Yes. Like this, you know, like this friendship is changing. But like you said, it doesn't mean that it's not still valuable. It doesn't mean that we don't still have some form of a relationship. And that was something that a lot of my, you know, my own experience has really taught me with like the post-graduation blues was so much is changing and sometimes I think it feels like it demands you to make big decisions. Like, okay, me and this person aren't connecting anymore. Well, they're not my friend. Like blank, blank slate, blank space. Like they're not my friend. This is all too much and just to cut people off or to feel very like emotional. And I think it is important to yet again be able to
recognize not just what you had, but what they still offer you just in a lesser capacity. And nothing is, I say this to people all the time and to myself all the time, nothing is ever going to come close to the relationship that you have with your university or your college friends, especially if you lived in the same house with them, especially if you lived in the same dorm or in the same like sorority or fraternity house. Like that is an incredibly heightened artificial way of like being around people, right? Like you do not see that anywhere else maybe than like marriage. And so you might not find relationships that are as close and as like intense,
but you might find people who like fit better with who you are now. Does that make sense? I love that. Yeah. To be willing to adapt and be okay with feelings. with relationships that don't feel the same as they did when you were in university. Yeah, because it's intense. Like, it's so intense.
It's incredibly artificial to have that level of like contact. You get to know people really quickly and you know so much about them. You know their routines. And it just doesn't always happen when you're after graduation. Yeah, because who has time to like spend every day together? Right. Because you're at work. Sometimes you're at multiple jobs and you have, you know, people meet their partners.
that's a big one I think that comes with like post-graduation blues is the shift from having a wide group of friends to maybe having, you know, your partner who often comes first and then the friends around that. And it's just like a whole relational shift. So we're going to take a break now. But when we come back, I want to talk to you about how we can cope with that shift, how we can embrace fear and some of your advice. 2%. That is the number of people. who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness,
and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like it. black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode. where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me,
your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth,
or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
Two more men who'd been the same thing. Grega lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So when it comes to post-graduation blues,
this might be an impossible question, but as a therapist, how long do you typically see it lasting? That is a challenging question because post-graduation blues, like I mentioned before, it's very similar to grief. And grief is going to be very individual.
It's going to depend on that person's circumstances. It's going to depend on how they've handled losses before. it's going to depend on their support systems. But I would say if the post-graduation blues are really impacting your ability to function, you know, after a couple of weeks or after a month or so. I mean, I mean, honestly, if you're suffering and it's really impacting your ability to, you know, function, you know, don't hesitate to reach out for support, whether that's individual therapy or group therapy can actually be really fantastic
because you get the benefits of therapy, but you're also healing in a group, which can have unique benefits. There's also really great books out there on self-development, you know, but I would really encourage folks that if they are having a hard time, and it's really impacting their ability to job search or to engage in self-care or their sleep suffering or they're not eating well or they're drinking too much or engaging, you really relying on mood altering substances. You know, that might be a sign that, that, okay, I've got to get some support. Oh, yeah, absolutely.
And I feel like it's, those are like all big, you know, big indicators that there is a level of coping that perhaps you're not adjusting to and that's totally okay. It's a huge change. But I do feel like if like after a year, you're still being, you're still thinking about oh, like I wish I was back there. There's such a deep sense of longing of like I would give anything to have that again or always reminiscing not being able to move on. I feel like most of the time those feelings should fade by that timeline.
我觉得这些都是很明显的迹象，你知道的，这说明你可能正在经历某种程度的心理应对，只是你还没完全适应，这完全没关系。这是一个巨大的改变。但我的确觉得，如果过了一年，你仍然在这样，你脑子里依然在想，哦，我真希望自己能回到过去。那种强烈的渴望感挥之不去，比如“我愿意付出一切来换回那种生活”，或者总是沉缅于过去、无法向前看。我觉得大多数时候，随着时间推移，这种感觉应该会逐渐淡去的。
Right. Like amongst the people around me, it was, you know, everyone still has those moments of being like, wow, like I really miss the structure of uni and I miss my friends and I miss like my life. But after like a year, it's kind of like, well, like, now I kind of like my new life. At that point, I would love to see someone investing in their new life and setting up new goals and figuring out other things that can bring them excitement and joy and meaning. Yeah. It's like you've had the time to mourn, hopefully, and then you've had the,
对的。比如我身边的人，你知道的，大家偶尔还是会有这种时刻，会觉得：“哇，我真的很怀念大学的结构化生活，想念我的朋友们，想念我当时的生活。”但一年之后，这种感觉就会变成：“好吧，我现在其实挺喜欢我的新生活的。”到了那个阶段，我很希望能看到有人把精力投入到新生活中去，设定新的目标，去寻找其他能带给自己兴奋感、快乐和意义的事物。对啊。这就好比，你已经有了足够的时间去哀悼，希望如此，然后你也有了……
like, the time to also perhaps be a little bit more proactive and also just settle, just settle in hard emotions. Like I feel like that is a part of, I feel like, you know, I'm guilty of doing this as well where it's always like, what can you be doing actively to like help yourself and to heal and to move forward? It's like sometimes it is just time and it is just like feeling again, comfortable with the discomfort, right? Right. And also accepting that there's going to be a part of you that is going to miss university forever. That that's, um, that that grief is going to be there because you really cared about that time of your life. And that was a really meaningful time of your life. And there is going to be a small part of you or a part of you that's going to, that is going to forever miss that. And that's okay. The reason that it's, that you miss it is because it was, it was important to you. I really like that sentiment. What kind of strategies or coping mechanisms do you think that recent graduates?
比如，也有时间去稍微变得积极主动一点，去平静地接纳那些艰难的情绪。我觉得这也是其中的一部分，而且我自己其实也会犯这种毛病，总是在想：“你到底能做些什么来积极地帮助自己、疗愈自己并继续前进？”但事实上，有时候你需要的只是时间，只是重新去习惯那种“不适感”，对吧？没错。同时也要接受这样一个事实：你身上总会有一部分，会永远怀念大学时光。这种悲伤会一直存在，因为你真的很在乎那段生命中的时光，那是一段对你意义非凡的日子。在你内心深处，总会有一个小小的部分，或者说一部分的你，会永远怀念那段时光。没关系。你之所以会怀念它，是因为它对你来说很重要。我很喜欢这种观点。你觉得刚毕业的学生可以采用什么样策略或应对机制……
can use to kind of manage the feelings of uncertainty, anxiety, but also nostalgia and the grief, as you spoke about. Right. So I always encourage my clients if they're not feeling right, they know that their mental health isn't where they want it to be, to really pay attention to the basics. And those are things like, you know, try to move your body every day in some way, drink water, get outside, pay attention to sleep, be really mindful about alcohol use because that can intensify feelings of anxiety and depression. So start with the basics and make sure you're getting some social outlets or some outlets to be creative. So that's a great place to start. I would also suggest that kind of what we talked about too, to start to learn how to engage
来应对那种不确定感、焦虑感，还有你刚才提到的那种怀旧情绪和悲伤感？好，所以我总是鼓励我的客户，如果他们感觉状态不对，意识到自己的心理健康不在自己希望的水平上，那就去关注最基础的事情。比如：每天尽力以某种方式活动一下身体，多喝水，去户外走走，注意睡眠，还要对酒精摄入保持警惕，因为酒精会加剧焦虑和抑郁的情绪。所以，从最基础的事情开始做起，确保自己有一些社交渠道，或者能发挥创造力的渠道。这是一个很好的起点。我还想建议一点，也就是我们刚才谈到的，开始去学习如何以一种稍微不同的方式去面对……
with your emotions a little bit differently to start to name what you're feeling, to accept what you're feeling, don't judge what you're feeling. And also really pay attention to your inner dialogue, because sometimes the way we talk to ourselves can be incredibly harsh and critical and mean. So I really encourage my clients to pay attention to how they're talking to themselves and to ask themselves, you know, what would I tell a good friend? You know, what advice would I give them? and to try to start treating themselves like they're a friend. I love that advice. And I say that to people all the time where it's like,
你的情绪，试着说出你到底有什么感受，去接纳你的感受，不要评判你的感受。同时，还要密切关注你内心的自我对话，因为有时候我们对自己说话的方式可能会极其严厉、苛刻和刻薄。所以我真的鼓励我的客户去留意他们是如何对自己说话的，并问问自己：“如果是一个好朋友，我会对他说什么呢？”“我会给他什么建议？”然后试着像对待朋友一样开始对待自己。我太喜欢这个建议了。我总是对人们说……
it's so much easier to be kind and to be compassionate and to be forgiving to other people and never as easy to do it to ourselves. So it's like, okay, if your best friend came to you and was like, I'm really worried that I'm never going to find my dream job, what would you say to them? You would probably say like, maybe your dream job doesn't exist yet. Maybe it's going to take some time. Maybe it isn't about what a dream job. Maybe it's about the life you create outside of work. Like there is so much
对别人保持善良、富有同情心、学会原谅要容易得多，但对自己这么做却从来都不容易。所以，如果你的好朋友来找你，对你说：“我真的很担心自己永远也找不到理想的工作”，你会对他们说什么？你可能会对他说：“也许你的理想工作现在还不存在呢，也许这需要一些时间；也许这并不取决于什么理想的工作，也许这取决于你在工作之余创造的生活。”你看，我们保留着那么多……
wisdom that we save for other people that would be so valuable for ourselves. I always find that. And the other thing I always say is like, especially with anxiety, anxiety and excitement feel very similar. Like you would, they have like the same. So true. Don't they have like the same physiological, like physical origins? Yeah, you know, your hands start getting if it's sweaty and get those butterflies in your stomach. Yeah, the physical symptoms of anxiety are really similar to excitement.
智慧是留给别人的，如果用在自己身上其实会非常有价值。我一直都有这种感觉。我总是挂在嘴边的另一件事是，特别是在面对焦虑时，焦虑和兴奋的感觉其实非常相似。比如，它们有着……太对了，它们的生理或身体根源不是一样的吗？对啊，你知道的，如果手心出汗了，胃里开始有那种小鹿乱撞的感觉。是的，焦虑的身体症状和兴奋真的非常相似。
Yeah. And so I'm always like, okay, yeah, that feeling could be anxiety. Like you're anxious about finding your own way. You're anxious about feeling lost. You're anxious about feeling lonely. Or you could be excited about the fact that you don't, now you don't have this huge time commitment anymore. Now, like, you could go traveling. Now, you do have more freedom to progress in your career rather than waiting to graduate before you really like get started. Now,
对啊。所以我总是会想：“好吧，这种感觉可能是焦虑，比如你为寻找自己的方向而焦虑，为感到迷茫而焦虑，为感到孤独而焦虑；或者，你也可以为这样一件事感到兴奋：你不再需要承担那么繁重的长期承诺了，现在你可以去旅行了，现在你确实有了更多追求职业发展的自由，而不必非要等到毕业才能真正开始。现在……”
you do have time to really choose friends that are really important, you know, that are maybe more suited to that part of your life that you're in, maybe rather than just like convenient as hard as that sounds. And more time to just like see life beyond education. Because I really find that what's so tricky about post-graduation is it is the first time ever that we are not within an educational environment. We, like this is our first time spending more than like four months since out of school. like that is going to be scary it's like i it's like a zoo animal like finally being released into
你确实有时间去认真挑选那些对你真正重要的朋友，你知道的，也许那些朋友更适合你当前的人生阶段，而不是仅仅因为图方便，尽管听起来可能有点刺耳。而且你有更多的时间去领略教育之外的人生。我真的发现，毕业后最棘手的地方在于，这是我们有生以来第一次不再处于教育环境中。我们……这就像是我们离开学校后，第一次花超过四个月的时间不在校园里，这会让人感到害怕，这就好象动物园里的动物终于被放归……
the wild right yeah i have a lot of clients who really struggle with not receiving regular feedback because their whole life going through school going through university they at every quarter every assignment every at the end of every semester at the end of every year they knew exactly where they stood they got a grade or they got a you know marks on pay on a paper or they got feedback from their professor, from their teacher. And now they're in this, in the work world or their job hunting. And there's no regular feedback. There's no clear indicator of like, how am I doing? And that's incredibly hard not to get that. And some of my work with clients involves learning how to give ourselves feedback and how to reflect on like,
大自然一样，对吧？是的，我的很多客户都非常难以适应“无法获得定期反馈”这一点，因为他们一辈子经历学校生活、大学生活的整个过程中，在每个季度、每次作业、每个学期末、每年结束时，他们都确切地知道自己处于什么位置。他们会得到一个分数，或者论文上得到了评分，或者得到了教授、老师的反馈。而现在，他们进入了职场，或者正在找工作，却没有任何定期的反馈。没有任何清晰的指标来告诉你“我做得怎么样”。得不到这些真的会让人极其难受。我为客户提供的一些辅导就包括：学习如何自己给自己提供反馈，以及如何反思……
what am I proud of or what did I do well today. And that's not easy because for our entire lives up until that point, we've been getting feedback in an academic setting. Now that you've said that, it's just like really hit me because I see that and there's so many people around me and like people who message me and people who are like my friends. And you're totally right. How do we know that we're doing a good job? We have absolutely no like parameter for it. We have no way of providing ourselves with the validation ourselves.
我今天有什么值得骄傲的，或者我今天什么事情做得很好。这并不容易，因为在我们人生迄今为止的全部时间里，我们都是在学术环境中获得反馈的。你这么一说，真的深深触动了我，因为我看着周围的很多人，包括那些给我发信息的人，还有我的朋友们，我都深有同感。你完全说对了。我们怎么知道自己是不是在好好工作呢？我们完全没有任何衡量标准，我们自己根本没有办法给我们自己提供这种认可。
And that's like crazy. How do you suggest people like check in with themselves and give feedback to themselves? So one activity to try if you're interested in journaling or even if you're not that into journaling, but just want to jot a few things down at the end of the day. But to ask yourself at the end of the day, you know, what were my wins? You know, what am I proud of? And your wins don't have to be huge. It doesn't have to be like, I got a job. You know, it could be your win could be, I went on a.
这太疯狂了。你觉得人们应该如何向自己进行内省并给自己提供反馈呢？所以，如果你对写日记感兴趣，或者即使你并不是那么热衷于写日记，但只是想在一天结束时随手记下几件事，有一个方法你可以尝试。那就是在一天结束时问问自己：“我今天的收获是什么？我有什么值得骄傲的？”你的收获不一定非要是惊天动地的大事，不需要是“我找到了一份工作”这种程度。你的收获可以是……
walk today. I updated my resume. I met a friend for coffee. I clean my kitchen. I mean, your wins could be anything, but just things that you're proud of that you did that created some positive momentum and to spend some time reflecting on those things and even writing them down because it's so incredibly easy to look at our to do list and to think, oh my gosh, I have so many more things that I, so many things I didn't get to or I have so much more I need to do. And then we forget to actually take stock of what we actually did. And it's important to give ourselves credit for those things and to reflect on what we are achieving. Oh, absolutely.
我今天去散步了，我更新了简历，我和朋友喝了咖啡，我打扫了厨房。我是说，你的收获可以是任何事，只要是你做的、能为你带来一些积极推动力的、让你感到骄傲的事情。花点时间反思这些事情，甚至把它们写下来，因为我们太容易看着自己的待办清单，然后心里想：“天哪，我还有这么多事情没做完，还有那么多事情等着我去做。”结果我们却忘了去盘点自己实际上已经完成了什么。认可我们所做的事情，并反思我们所取得的成就，这是非常重要的。哦，绝对是这样。
And the other thing is actually make goals for the next year because a lot of the time you end up meeting them. And I know that sounds wild, but once you have made it, obviously the goals cannot be like, I want to be a millionaire by 2025 because that's another. achievable. But if you were like, yeah, I really want to have a job by this time next year. I really want to have a thousand dollars in savings, whatever it is. You will often find that there will come a point where you will get back to get, get to look back at that entry. And you're like, okay, I actually did that. And there is a sense of pride there that feels very similar to the pride you would get when you got an A or when you completed something like
另一件要做的事，其实是为接下来的一年设定目标，因为很多时候你最终真的会实现它们。我知道这听起来有点疯狂，但一旦你制定了目标——当然，目标不能是“我想在2025年成为百万富翁”，因为那不太现实。但如果你说的是：“是的，我真的很想在明年这个时候找到工作，我真的很想有一千美元的存款”，无论具体是什么，你往往会发现，总会有那么一个时刻，当你回过头去看当时的记录时，你会想：“好吧，我真的做到了。”那种油然而生的自豪感，和你在考试中拿了“A”或者完成某项任务时获得的自豪感……
an assignment or an exam. It might not be the same, in the same environment, it might not be of the same like the same stakes. But I feel like also our baseline for what feels like an achievement also kind of decreases in a sense as well. Right. Yeah, I love that. Being able to set realistic goals and get that sense of accomplishment when you meet that goal or when you take action towards that goal. well that really leads to my next question you've provided me with the segue which is you know if if you are a racing graduate how do you set realistic goals and expectations about yourself and your life during this transitional period how do you stop yourself from setting me i want to be a millionaire goal or i want to be a CEO goal so one thing i encourage my clients to do is to take a look at their
感觉非常相似。虽然可能不是在同一个环境中，可能也没有那么高的利害关系。但我觉得，我们在某种意义上，对“什么才算是一种成就”的心理底线其实也降低了。对吧？是的，我太喜欢这个观点了。能够设定现实的目标，并在达成目标或为之采取行动时获得那种成就感。嗯，这正好引出了我的下一个问题，你给我做了一个很好的铺垫，那就是：如果你是一个刚毕业的学生，在这个过渡期里，你该如何为自己和生活设定现实的目标和期望呢？你该如何阻止自己去设定诸如“我想成为百万富翁”或“我想成为CEO”这样的目标呢？所以，我鼓励客户去做的第一件事，就是审视他们的……
values and to spend some time identifying what their values are because that can help shape what goals they want to achieve. For example, if they value travel, then that might impact what types of goals they set or if they value community or if they value financial stability. Once you identify your values, that can really help be a guidepost for setting goals that are going to be in line with what you want and are going to be realistic. Also, I, I, I, just want to throw out there too that if you sat an ambitious goal and you don't need it, that's okay. Maybe you've got part of the way there. So I think it's okay to, to, you know, if you don't meet your goal, that's not the worst thing, worst thing in the world because chances
价值观，花点时间明确自己的价值观是什么，因为这有助于塑造他们想要实现的目标。例如，如果他们重视旅行，那可能会影响他们设定的目标类型；或者如果他们重视社群，或者重视财务稳定。一旦你明确了自己的价值观，这就能真正成为指引你设定符合自己心愿且切合实际的目标的风向标。另外，我还想顺便提一句，如果你设定了一个雄心勃勃的目标却没有达成，那也没关系。也许你已经完成了其中的一部分。所以我觉得，即使你没有达到目标，也不是世界上最糟糕的事，因为大概率……
are you, you definitely made progress. And you know what? This might sound a little bit wild to say, but there are a lot of people out there who never would, that like never would have dreamed of even setting that goal, who never would have even thought it possible to suggest that to themselves. So it's pretty amazing that you were that ambitious in the first place. It shows a lot of gusto. Yeah, absolutely. And the other thing that I always think about is what's the rush? Like, what's the rush? Right. What, like the, well, the average age to graduate in the U.S. is 22, 22? Yeah, that sounds about right. 21, 22, somewhere in that range.
你肯定已经取得了进步。你知道吗？这听起来可能有点疯狂，但现实中有很多很多、甚至做梦都不敢去设定那个目标的人，他们甚至从未想过向自己提出这样的要求。所以，你最初能有那么大的雄心壮志，这已经很了不起了，这展现了十足的魄力。是的，绝对如此。另一个我经常思考的问题是：到底在急什么？对吧，到底在急什么？美国大学毕业生的平均年龄是22岁，对吧？是的，听起来差不多。21岁、22岁，差不多在这个范围。
That's wild to me, because that is so young. That is so. young. There's a lot of life to live. Yeah. And I'm sure you're probably, you would probably look at some of those people and then like, you are, you're a child. Like you, I wish I was that young again. Like, you have no idea there's so much time. And I always talk about like the seasons of life and like, you are at like, you're in like season one of your like 21 part TV series. Like you are only just beginning. There are so many relationships and so much character development to happen, like so many plot twists. Don't you want to save some of the best things for a little while later? Like if you achieved everything you want within the next like two to three years,
这对我来说太疯狂了，因为他们还那么年轻，真的太年轻了。人生还有很长要走呢。是的。而且我敢肯定，你可能会看着其中的一些人，然后心里想：“你还是个孩子呢，我多希望能再年轻一次啊。”你根本不知道时间还有很多。我经常谈论人生的不同季节，你现在就像是在你的21集电视剧里演第一季呢，一切才刚刚开始。未来还有那么多的关系要建立，那么多的性格塑造要完成，还有无数的剧情反转。难道你不想把一些最美好的事情留到稍微靠后一点的时候吗？如果你在接下来的一两年里就把想要的一切都实现了……
what's next? Yeah. And you bring up such a good point. Something I see a lot with my clients is a frustration where they really want to do meaningful work. And but oftentimes your first job out of college or university, the tasks that you're going to be given may not feel that meaningful, that they might feel kind of boring or inconsequential and being able to have patience to realize that this is a stepping zone and this is a way to get experience and this is a way to learn what you do like in a work environment and what you don't like in a work environment. Like all of this is really valuable information that you're going to use in the future. And to be okay with the fact that this isn't a perfect fit right now, but you're getting this
那接下来该怎么办？是的。你提出了一个非常好的观点。我从我的客户身上经常看到的一种现象是，他们会感到沮丧，因为他们非常渴望去做有意义的工作。但通常情况下，你大学毕业后的第一份工作，你被指派的任务可能感觉并没有那么有意义，它们可能会显得有点枯燥或微不足道。能够拥有耐心去意识到这只是一个跳板，这是积累经验的一种方式，也是了解你在工作环境中喜欢什么、不喜欢什么的一种途径——所有这些都是极其宝贵的财富，你将来都会用得上。并且要接受这样一个事实：虽然现在并不是完美契合，但你正在获取……
information that's going to help you in your next step, get you closer and closer. to what you really want to be doing. I love that point because I think that's something that I rarely speak about on the show. It is the drive not just for money, but for purpose and for meaning. And we are like such a lucky generation that that is something that we could, we understand is like on the cards for us, right? Like the choice of meaningful work is something that we do have available to us. But sometimes you don't know what your mission is yet.
这些信息将帮助你迈出下一步，让你越来越接近你真正想做的事。我非常喜欢这个观点，因为我觉得我在节目中很少讨论这一点。人们对工作的追求不仅仅是为了金钱，更是为了追求目标感和意义感。我们是非常幸运的一代人，我们意识到这种追求对我们来说是可能的，对吧？寻找有意义的工作确实是我们能够拥有的选择。但有时你还不知道自己的使命是什么……
and there is an experience waiting for you in that dead end job or waiting for you in that internship or in that graduate role, that is like the point where you turn over the page. And if you go out looking for meetings straight away, you're going to actually end up missing the thing that would have provided you with that gateway. So it's kind of like just take the experiences for what they are in a way. Like take the experiences for what they might be leading you to. Like not everything is the final destination. That's like.
而那份枯燥的工作中，或者那段实习经历、应届生岗位中，其实正有一段经历在等着你，那将成为你翻开新篇章的关键节点。如果你一开始就急于寻找生活的意义，你反而可能会错过那个能为你提供通往意义之门的契机。所以，某种程度上，不妨就坦然接受这些经历原本的模样吧。把这些经历看作是指引你走向未来的道路，并非所有经历都是最终目的地。这就好比……
Exactly. I think that's for everything. I want to wrap up by asking you for one final piece of advice or some words of wisdom that you would get, you would give to somebody listening right now who has graduated maybe in the last six months last year. He was like, I have no idea what I am doing. What would you say to them? I would encourage them to practice self-compassion. So self-compassion was developed by Dr. Kristen Neff,
完全赞同。我觉得对所有事情都是这样。最后，我想请你给现在正在收听节目、可能在过去六个月或一年内刚刚毕业的人，给出最后一条建议或几句肺腑之言。他们现在的心态大概是：“我完全不知道自己在干什么。”你会对他们说些什么？我会鼓励他们去实践自我同情。自我同情这个概念是由克里斯汀·内夫博士（Dr. Kristen Neff）提出的……
and it's a really wonderful concept because she talks a lot about how we've been taught to chase self-esteem. But self-esteem often really involves how we stack up against other people, and it involves external accomplishments and checking the boxes. And so self-esteem is going to rise and fall, depending on what's going on in our world and how we're stacking up against other people. Self-compassion, on the other hand, is more about the relationship that we have with ourselves. And it's about treating ourselves like a friend, like we talked about earlier. And it's about really offering ourselves some compassion and some grace.
这是一个非常棒的概念，因为她谈到很多关于我们从小被教育去追逐自尊。但自尊往往更多地涉及到我们与他人的比较，涉及到外部的成就和打勾完成任务。因此，自尊心会起起伏伏，这取决于我们周围发生了什么，以及我们与他人相比处于什么位置。与此相反，自我同情更多的是关于我们与自己的关系。它是关于像对待朋友一样对待自己，就像我们刚才谈到的那样。它是关于真正给予自己一些同情和包容。
And when you start to practice self-compassion, some really wonderful things can happen. It's much easier to maintain motivation because you're not getting completely defeated when you get a curveball. So I really want people to start paying attention to how they're treating themselves and how they're talking do themselves and to treat themselves with self-compassion. I love that. What's one way that somebody could show themselves some self-compassion after listening to this? One way to show yourself self-compassion is that if you're feeling frustrated or disappointed
当你开始练习自我同情时，一些非常美好的事情就会发生。保持动力会变得容易得多，因为当你遇到突发挫折时，你不会彻底被击垮。所以我真的很希望人们开始关注自己是如何对待自己、如何对自己说话的，并学会用自我同情来善待自己。我太喜欢这个了。听完这段话后，人们可以采取什么具体方式来向自己展现自我同情呢？展现自我同情的一种方法是，如果你感到沮丧、失望……
or you feel like you've made a mistake is to ask yourself, you know, what would I say to a friend? What would I say to someone else? and to take that advice for yourself. You know, for example, if I do some writing and it doesn't turn out well or it doesn't get well received, you know, to ask myself, well, what would I say to a friend? And I might say to a friend like, hey, you can't be perfect all the time or, you know, you're trying or the next one's going to be better.
或者觉得自己犯了错误，不妨问问自己：“我会对朋友说些什么？我会对别人说些什么？”然后把这个建议用在自己身上。例如，如果我写了一些东西，结果写得不好或者没有得到很好的反响，我会问自己：“好吧，我会对朋友说些什么？”我可能会对朋友说：“嘿，你不可能永远都完美，你在努力尝试，下一篇会更好的。”
And that'll keep you moving so that you can figure out what your next step's going to be. Yeah. I often like thinking about it as well as like your child. self is still very much alive and present within you, like show them the kindness that you would show them if they were right in front of you right now. So thank you so much for all of your wisdom, for all of your free wisdom on this topic of post-graduation blues. I really appreciate you coming on. Oh my gosh. This has been so much fun. Thank you for having me. It's been wonderful talking with you. Oh my gosh, me too. I feel like I was unlocking so much of my own experiences that I had,
这样能推动你继续前进，让你能够弄清楚自己的下一步该怎么走。是的。我经常这样想，其实你内心中那个“童年的自己”依然非常鲜活地存在于你的体内，去给予他们那种关怀吧，就像如果他们此刻就站在你面前你会给予他们的一样。非常感谢你分享的智慧，感谢你在这个关于“毕业后低谷期”的话题中倾囊相授免费的建议。非常感激你能来做客。天哪，这太有趣了。谢谢你邀请我来。和你的交谈非常美妙。天哪，我也是。我觉得我好像解锁了许多我自己的经历，那些……
I've thought about in quite a while. So where can they find you? Where can the listeners find you, your book? More of your advice. So you can find me on my website. So it's Liz Kellymsw.com. And I'm also on Instagram at real. Dot life. Mental.com wellness. No, that's a little bit of a mouthful. But I can also send you everything if you want to be able to link it to the show. Yeah, I'll do that. And your book as well, wait. your book and your book as well. Yes. And so my book is called, This Book is Cheaper Than Therapy, a No Nonsense Guide to Improving Your Mental Health. It has tools that I share with my clients every day. It's really the basics of my version of Mental
我已经有一段时间没去想过的经历了。那么，听众们在哪里能找到你呢？他们去哪里能找到你、你的书，以及你更多的建议呢？你可以在我的网站上找到我，网址是 LizKellymsw.com。我还在 Instagram 上，账号是 real.dot life.Mental.com wellness。不对，这个名字有点太拗口了。不过我也可以把所有链接发给你，如果你想把它们放在节目简介里的话。好的，我会的。还有你的书，等等……还有你的书也是。对的，我的书名叫作《这本书比看心理医生便宜：改善心理健康的无废话指南》（This Book is Cheaper Than Therapy, a No Nonsense Guide to Improving Your Mental Health）。里面包含了我和客户每天分享的实用工具，这真的是我版本的心理健康……
Health, the basics of mental health. And you can find that wherever you'd like to buy books. There's also an audio version and an electronic version too. Look at that. Accessible. And also we love an audiobook because you can listen to it like you're listening to this podcast. Thank you so much again for coming on. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. If you have a friend, a sibling, I don't know,
心理健康的基础知识。你可以在任何你想买书的地方买到它。还有有声书版本和电子书版本。你看，多方便。而且我们都很喜欢有声书，因为你可以像听播客一样听它。非常感谢你再次光临节目。和往常一样，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何平台上留下五星好评。如果你有一个朋友、兄弟姐妹，或者……
an acquaintance who was just graduated and might need to hear this, send them a link. I'm sure they would appreciate the amazing advice and words of wisdom from our guest. And of course, make sure you're following along and send me any episode suggestions. feedback, thoughts, feelings, qualms on Instagram at that psychology podcast. Until next time, stay safe, stay kind, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我不知道，某个刚刚毕业、可能需要听听这些内容的熟人，就把链接发给他们吧。我相信他们一定会感激我们嘉宾提供的精彩建议和智慧之言。当然，也别忘了关注我们，并向我发送任何关于节目的建议、反馈、想法、感受或疑问，可以发到 Instagram 的“that psychology podcast”账号。下次见，保重，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们很快再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神韧性、体能训练以及在我们这个奇妙的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦……
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that Trust your girlfriends
当你和一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个高产的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说：相信你的女朋友们。
Listen to the girlfriends Trust me babe On the IHartRadio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcast On the look back at it podcast From 1979 That was a big moment for me
收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》，可在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back At It》播客中……1979年对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。
84 is big to me I'm Sam J And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a here unpack what went down And try to make sense Of how we survived it
1984对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J）和我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends Fellow Comedians and Favorite offers Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员以及我们喜爱的嘉宾一起，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。对于黑人来说，再也没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听的是由你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人科尔·甘斯（Kear Games）主持的《从头学起》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不安全、无法坦诚进行的对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人披着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档iHeart播客，保证由真人创作。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。